maintenant
de revenir et de détailler l'une des
annonces les plus attendues de la
semaine le plan de résilience économique
et social il a été dévoilé cet après
midi par le premier ministre jean castex
vient en aide aux entreprises les plus
consommatrices d'énergie aux pêcheurs ou
encore aux agriculteurs les détails
jérôme vallier
après le coup de pouce de 15 centimes
par litre à la pompe pour les
particuliers place aux mesures pour les
entreprises qui font face aux
conséquences de la guerre en ukraine
dans l'immédiat les entreprises les plus
consommatrices d'énergie qui subiraient
des pertes cette année pourront être
aidés avec la prise en charge de 50 % du
surcoût énergétique et pour les plus
impactés les mécanismes dette cowitz ont
réactivé les outils qui ont fait leurs
preuves pendant la crise sanitaire
seront de nouveau mobilisés et adaptée
aux spécificités de cette crise les
prêts garantis par l'état peuvent être
prolongées ou contracter le report de
charges réactiver et le recours à
l'activité partielle prolongée pas
question non plus de laisser des
secteurs entiers à l'arrêt pour cause de
coût trop important des carburants ou
des matières premières en particulier
les pêcheurs pour qui le prix du
carburant est essentielle avec comme
priorité absolue le maintien des
activités de pêche qui contribue à notre
souveraineté alimentaire le secteur
bénéficiera ainsi d'une aide de 35
centimes par litre de carburant dès
demain 16 mars les collectivités locales
pourront aussi aider de leur côté parmi
les autres secteurs concernés jean
castex a présenté des dispositifs pour
les éleveurs le transport routier le btp
ou encore les entreprises qui exportent
des premières mesures d'urgence qui
pourrait évoluer en fonction de la suite
du conflit a prévenu le premier ministre
qui a aussi détaillé une vision à plus
long terme avec l'objectif de sortir
intégralement du gaz et du pétrole
russes d'ici 2027
plus largement l'accélération de sortie
des énergies fossiles doit être amplifié
comme la reconquête d'une souveraineté
industrielles et alimentaires
comment encaisser le choc économique de
la guerre mais aussi quelles mesures
pour le pouvoir d'achat voilà on fait
régulièrement dans cette émission des
gros plans des débats sur les programmes
des candidates et des candidats je vous
présente mes invités anne sophie lcif
bonsoir osait sa professeur à
l'université paris 1 panthéon sorbonne
chef économiste chez bdo france eric
delannoy bonsoir économiste président
fondateur du cabinet tenzing vous
soutenez emmanuel macron julien oudoul
bonsoir de la soirée parole du
rassemblement national président du
groupe rassemblement national au conseil
régional de bourgogne franche comté avec
nous en duplex en visioconférence thomas
porte qui est membre du parlement de
l'union populaire de jean luc mélenchon
bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi matthieu
croissandeau évidemment est resté à mes
côtés peut-être eu une réaction un peu
général à ce plan de résidents je
commence avec vous eric delannoy c'était
impossible de faire autrement ça les
aider ces secteurs fortement impacté on
a un peu l'impression que le
gouvernement en cours après l'inflation
en permanence mais c'est un peu le
problème c'est que il ya une inflation
qui est ce qu'on appelle une inflation
importée en fait hein c'est à dire qu'en
gros il ya une première inflation qui
était lié à un problème
d'approvisionnement liées aux qu'ovide
et qui était soutenu par une demande
très forte donc un décalage entre
l'offre et la demande une offre qui est
qu'on n'arrive pas à soutenir parce
qu'il ya des problèmes
d'approvisionnement et une demande qui
est très forte quand tu la sortie du
coït ce phénomène là est en train de se
faire un documentaire avec justement la
guerre en ukraine pourquoi la guerre en
ukraine est un problème d'offre et n'est
pas un problème de demande parce que le
choc d'offre il existe le choc de
demande n'existe pas aujourd'hui mais en
revanche tous les coûts de production
augmentent parce que le blé parce que
les énergies et donc ce qu'ils avaient
déjà comme déséquilibre entre l'offre et
la demande qui générer de l'inflation
c'est un déséquilibre qui est en train
d'augmenter et donc les skis a été mis
en place là c'est vraiment un plan qui
consiste à essayer de baisser les
problématiques de deux coups sur l'offre
de manière à faire en sorte de
satisfaire la demande avec des prix qui
nous montrent pas trop donc on est bien
sur un plan et ça c'est vraiment de
comprendre qui n'est pas un plan de
soutien à la demande ce qui explique qu
il ya moins de mesures sur les
particuliers mais qui est vraiment un
soutien sur l'offre lié à cette guerre
julien où ce plan comment vous le
percevez les dernières mesures annoncées
par jean castex celle ci est ce que vous
jugez à la mesure de l'impact de ces
sanctions économiques contre la russie
puis plus généralement de la guerre où
il est à la mesure en tout cas de la
volonté du président macron de faire
oublier son bilan en matière des de
pouvoir d'achat des français c'est un
plan électoralistes c'est un plan qui
arrive à quelques jours du premier tour
de l'élection présidentielle je rappelle
un quelques chiffres et je rappelle une
réalité déjà c'est que les français
souffrent du pouvoir d'achat depuis
plusieurs mois bien avant la guerre en
ukraine et quelques chiffres sur
finalement la réalité du pouvoir d'achat
qui s'est considérablement et rodez dans
notre pays il ya un français sur trois
qui n'arrivent plus à se soigner faute
de moyens il ya un français sur quatre
se sont les chiffres du secours
populaire qui ne mange pas à sa faim
dans notre pays il ya un français sur
cinq qui a froid chez lui parce qu'ils
n'arrivent pas à payer ses factures
d'énergie c'est ça la réalité du bilan
de monsieur macron et c'est pas le
résultat de la guerre en ukraine donc là
on voit bien que le gouvernement et le
maquereau dégaine opportunément au
dernier moment au dernier moment parce
que marine le pen alerte sur la crise du
pouvoir d'achat depuis le mois de
septembre pourquoi depuis le mois de
septembre parce qu'en septembre on a
dépassé le niveau des prix des
carburants de l'avant gilet jaune qui
avait provoqué cette révolte contre le
matraquage fiscal on a alerté sur les
difficultés de bon nombre de ménages qui
aujourd'hui font le choix entre le plein
de courses entre le plein d'essence
entre se chauffer ou se soigner ça n'a
jamais été entendu par le gouvernement
pour qui n'a jamais voulu la seule
mesure 1 pérenne concrètes et durables
qui la baisse des taxes alors ce
gouvernement va rendre dollar je
détaillerai les propositions de marine
le pen sur cette question un mot de
réponse est oui fin mai sur enfin je
m'attendais à ce type de réaction je
pense que l'insee doit certainement être
un appareil d'état mais parce que
l'insee dit clairement que la hausse du
pouvoir d'achat existe depuis depuis
2018 et qu'elle n'a pas été aussi élevé
depuis une quinzaine d'années donc cette
réalité du pouvoir d'achat est une
véritable réalité pour l'ensemble des
français les emails de manière au milieu
malien de manière du mans domaine de
manière de me ce sont des chiffres
nationaux bien évidemment il ya des
disparités en fonction des déciles c'est
vrai mais on sait les expliquer elle
sait pas s'il nous faut expliquer alors
oui c'est en gros la partie des
paisibles la partie des personnes les
plus riches par rapport à la partie des
personnes les plus pauvres il n'empêche
que une réalité qui est concrète c'est
que tous ceux qui travaillent ont eu un
pouvoir d'achat qui a augmenté depuis
2010 9 ses supérieurs à 3 signé pour
cent par an et ça n'avait pas été fait
depuis 20 ans donc tout ça a mis ce
temps fou ça regardez vos stats il
souffre en ce qu'il soit imprimé sur le
terrain moyen mais les vraies
souffrances ne peuvent être une france
qui n'existe pas mais mais mais le
problème c'est qu avez-vous on
généralise tout en fait et c'est comme
ça qu'on arrive est révolu c'est qu'on a
réussi lui tn o qui n'annoncent
dramatique il faut bien vous allez
choisir les personnes c'est tout pour
revenir par rapport à ces chiffres en
effet l'insee par rapport en
construisait un indicateur et surtout
l'insee par rapport à son travail
justement se base sur le pouvoir d'achat
des français sur ce justement ces
tickets de caisse et sur les paniers
moyens donc la résultante du
statistiques c'est vraiment les français
qui vont faire leurs courses elle les
français qui paient leurs dépenses c'est
pas quelque chose comme ça ex nihilo qui
est mis en oeuvre et d'ailleurs c'est
une méthodologie qui n'est pas reconnue
et adopté que par la france mais qui a
adapté au niveau de l'euro de l'europe
puisque même eurostat et des autres
institutions pendant peut-être que tout
le monde ment mais en tout cas les
chiffres sont là donc après on peut
contester d'accord ou pas mais il ya un
fait scientifique et que en effet le
pouvoir d'achat a augmenté notamment
fortement l'année dernière est
d'ailleurs c'est la résultante du quoi
qu'il en coûte il faut bien vu le coût
que ça vu que c'est quand même des
impacts positifs concernant les ménages
et les entreprises en corse et les
chiffres qui le disent et par rapport à
ce que vous dites en effet la difficulté
c'est que c'est vraiment une inflation
énergétique et donc on voit que toutes
les mesures
et à mon sens c'est vrai que ça devrait
être plutôt que des fois peut-être de
faire des chèques un peu inflation à
tout le monde en tout cas économiquement
ce qui serait plus efficace c'est le
lien par rapport à votre revenu vous
avez un rôle vue qui assez important
bien sûr vous avez une augmentation du
prix de l'énergie eh bien ça ne va pas
forcément remettre en cause les
fondamentaux de votre consommation
pareil pour les entreprises qui ont
quand même des taux de marge qu'ils là
aussi grâce aux codes qu'il en coûte ont
plutôt bien par contre la difficulté
c'est des entreprises dans certains
secteurs et des ménages à peu près 6
millions de ménages qui sont en effet
très précaire au niveau de l'énergie
vous pouvez vraiment avoir une très
forte hausse des inégalités c'est des
gens dont vous parlez est justement
exactement à mon sens les aides devrait
vraiment être concentré sur ces mêmes la
gela qui en effet vont vraiment subir
cette inflation de tomblaine alors
effectivement le jeu il y avait eu ces
quinze centimes de hristo on annoncé par
litre de carburant à partir du premier à
vide pour tous les français jean castex
l'a élargie au gaz naturel véhicule et
au gpl voilà ça fait partie des annonces
de cette journée on n'a pas encore
entendu thomas porte que que propose
jean luc mélenchon je sais qu'il vise
par exemple et les bénéfices de total
évidemment puisqu'on a eu un certain
nombre d' annonce du premier ministre
qui ne répondent pas à l'urgence de la
situation et encore une fois on va faire
des chèques faire des ristournes pour
essayer de mettre un coup d'arrêt à la
hausse des prix et en exonère celles et
ceux qui sont enrichis de façon
astronomique pendant la crise moi je le
rappelle ici total ces 7 milliards de
dividendes versés aux actionnaires et 16
milliards de bénéfices réalisés en 2021
c'est-à-dire un record absolu en france
depuis le début du capitalisme donc
quand est ce qu'on va taxer celles et
ceux qui aujourd'hui s'enrichissent
alors que les français souffrent et
quand j'entends les commentaires
d'autosatisfaction de ce gouvernement là
on a 10 millions de porcs ça a été dit
on a eu huit millions de personnes à
l'aide alimentaire on a des gens qui
n'arrivent pas se chauffer on a 12
millions de prêts car nrj et on a
l'impression en plus dans les annonces
du gouvernement qu'on découvre
l'explosion du prix de l'énergie et
qu'on la lit à la guerre en ukraine ça
fait des années aujourd'hui que
l'énergie et les prix des factures
explosent mais c'est pas le résultat du
hasard que c'est le fait de la
libéralisation de ce marché là par
exemple la cgt a amené une étude là
dessus a dit que depuis
1004 et l'ouverture à la concurrence et
la privatisation du secteur du gaz il ya
une hausse des tarifs de 120% pour
l'énergie pour l'électricité c'est
depuis 2007 on estime que ces 20% donc
nous on a une proposition majeure là
dessus par exemple c'est un pôle public
de l'énergie pour renationaliser les
entreprises publiques de ces secteurs et
permettre que chacune et chacun puisse
avoir par exemple la gratuité des
premiers watts que nous avons eu que
nous avons chiffré dans notre programme
et qui est une mesure de dignité on peut
pas accepter aujourd'hui que dans ce
pays des gens fn déjà n'arrive pas
chauffé déjà n'arrive pas à se déplacer
alors qu'on a des multinationales qui
ont touché en plus de l'argent public et
qui se gavent à longueur d'année
justement ce n'est pas ces débats il
nous sert une vous servent à prendre à
bras le corps les programmes des
candidats des candidats et je voudrais
entendre vos propositions j'imagine que
vous n'êtes pas sur la même ligne a
notamment sur je sais pas les bénéfices
de total peut-être que si ou le constat
fait à l'instant par thomas porte pour
jean luc mélenchon si le constat qui est
fait c'est celui qui fait aussi par
marine le pen sur le fait déjà qui a eu
des spéculateurs et des profiteurs de
guerre et les profiteurs de crise
visiblement ils sont épargnés par le
gouvernement ensuite il ya la
responsabilité
[Musique]
effectivement nous avons été les grands
perdants du marché européen de l'énergie
pourquoi parce qu'en france nous avons
une énergie extrêmement peu cher grâce
au nucléaire d'ailleurs qui est un
fleuron est un atout formidable qui
étaient dénigrés par monsieur mâcon
pendant quatre ans et la dernière année
finalement il est revenu donc ce marché
européen de l'énergie qui la conséquence
c'est quoi c'est tout simplement de
coupler le prix du gaz à celui de
l'électricité donc plus le gaz augmente
plus l'électricité augmenté ce qui
pénalise les ménages français évidemment
et ensuite nous ce que nous proposons à
ce que marine le pen propose depuis des
mois c'est la baisse de la tva de 20% à
5 5 sur les produits énergétiques en
faire des produits de première nécessité
le diesel l'essence le fioul électricité
et le gaz c'est rendre 12 milliards
d'euros en français et c'est extrêmement
important en ce moment et c'est la seule
mesure durable parce que le gel du prix
du gaz n'est pas une mesure du rap c'est
une mesure déjà extrêmement restrictif
qu'elle ne concerne que 3 millions de
consommateurs et non pas les 10000 sur
les 10 millions et surtout c'est une
mesure qui est impactée par la
fluctuation du prix du gaz et on voit
bien qu'aujourd'hui si le cette mesure
donc été opéré cette mesure coûterait
très cher puisque serait 9 milliards
d'euros voilà donc la seule valeur du
crédit mega tv c'est la tva de 20 à 5 5
qu'est ce que vous en pensez mais bon en
fait c'est un peu ce que je disais en
préambule c'est à dire que la tva
pourrait être une bonne idée si elle
crée une différenciation sur la
consommation des ménages or aujourd'hui
la tva est un art aux inflation en fait
c'est tard qu'en gros on va baisser on
va baisser artificiellement les prix
donc finalement il va ailleurs une
différence forte on va stimuler une
demande qui n'a pas besoin d'être
stimulée c'est pour ça que j'ai insisté
sur le fait qu' on est sur un choc
d'offre on n'est pas sur un choc de
demande et donc ce ne sont pas des
mesures générales qu'il faut mettre en
place ce sont des mesures ciblées pour
faire en sorte que l'offre se rétablisse
c'est à dire qu'on en baisse le coût et
c'est ça qui est très important alors
après on culpabilise tout le monde sur
le fait qu'il ya des pauvres il ya des
preuves ya des points bien c'est vrai il
ya des ports et c'est très malheureux et
je dois dire que par rapport à ce qu'on
entend sur le fait qu'il ya des gens qui
n'arrivent plus à soigner je veux dire
que ici il ya une personne qui en vingt
ans a fait quelque chose pour les gens
arrivent à soigner c'est le reste à
charge aux héros dans le bilan a été
fait et qui montre que ça bénéficie à
des millions de français donc faut
arrêter avec cette démagogie sur le
thème qu'il n'y a que des pauvres en
france il ya autre chose que des pauvres
s'ils les ports il faut les aider c'est
bien évident ça a été aidé par le cheik
inflation ça a été aidé par lé la
protection sur le bouclier énergétique
et il ya d'autres choses certainement à
mettre en place il ya une revalorisation
de tous les minima sociaux il n'y a pas
que ça il ya aussi 175 milliards de
dedans de départ qui a été constituée
l'ordre du coc vide c'est 60 175
milliards d'epargne une fin ils ne
demandent qu'à être dépensés en fait et
c'est pour ça qu'il faut pas
prioritairement sauf pour les plus
pauvres de manière ciblée soutenir la
demande il faut une fois plus soutenir
l'offre et c'est bien l'objectif de ce
plan aujourd'hui c'est de soutenir
l'offre en baissant les prix des coûts
et la production sur l'énergie et les
matières premières alors j'aimerais
qu'on parle de la dette maintenant et
j'ai d'abord ouvrir cette séquence en
réécoutant un passage la prise de parole
du premier ministre cet après midi jean
castex qui a égrainé les mesures prises
depuis la rentrée pour justement
maîtriser l'impact de la hausse des prix
de l'énergie on écoute le premier
ministre
depuis la rentrée de septembre dernier
l'état a engagé près de 20 milliards
d'euros pour maîtriser les impacts des
hausses du prix de l'énergie en
particulier le tarif du gaz est bloqué
depuis le 1er octobre et la hausse des
tarifs de l'électricité a été limitée à
4% en 2022 un chèque énergie
exceptionnelle a été mis en place dès la
hausse du prix des carburants fin
octobre dernier nous avons mis en place
une indemnité inflation de 100 euros qui
a été versée à 38 millions de personnes
nous avons également revalorisée
l'indemnité kilométrique
alors il ya ces annonces et ce bilan
fait par jean castex mais on a voulu
avec quentin calmèrent rebond soit
contactez nous
faire le bilan du quoi qu'il en coûte
qu'est ce qu'il y avait exactement dans
ce petit défi effectivement lancé ce
matin les essayer de savoir ce qu'est
exactement dans le quoi qu'il en coûte
quoi qu'il en coûte ce sont les mots
prononcés le 12 mars 2020 pour faire
face à l'épidémie de kovy d' on a un
coût total qui est difficile à définir
aurait par exemple on a un ministre et
olivier du soft qui a parlé dans les
échos c'était en janvier dernier d'une
facture globale une facture nette en
quelque sorte de plus de 140 milliards
d'euros mais depuis on parle on a paré
au cabinet de vie du soft qui disent que
ce chiffre il a été surélevée à sont là
parce qu'il ya eu une meilleure
croissance que prévu donc la facture
sera moins en moins salée en quelque
sorte en quelque sorte mais donc pour se
faire une idée précise des principaux
postes de dépenses on a épluché par
exemple le rapport de la cour des
comptes qui a été publié en juillet 2021
et dans l'ordre vient par exemple la
cour a noté que le fonds de solidarité
est bien à lui seul ouvert donc pour les
petites entreprises il a coûté au total
11,8 milliards d'euros en 2020 ce
chiffre il a représenté 30 milliards en
2021 l'activité partielle a représenté
par exemple 26 2 milliards en 2020 un
chiffre qui a grimpé à 35 milliards en
2021 il ya aussi toutes les dépenses de
santé liées à la pandémie pour
schématiser on a repris les dépenses
liées à l'ondam qui est le chiffre des
dépenses de l'assurance maladie hélas il
n'a une prévision on voit qu'on essaie
de la prévision parce que on était à 200
milliards s'est passé à 218 milliards et
224 en 2021 et donc si on prend ces
trois mesures là qu'on vient d'énumérer
donc fonds de solidarité chômage chômage
partiel et coût pour l'assurance maladie
sur deux ans ça représente 127 milliards
rien que ces trois dépenses là pour
donner un ordre d'idée me comparer
parés de ministères exactement mais on a
le budget des ministères on a le schéma
comme ça dd grand budget est le
principal le premier poste de dépense
pour l'état c'est celui de
l'enseignement scolaire à lui seul c'est
77,8 milliards thomas merci beaucoup
quand l'un des défis relevés ainsi fia
si ça va s'arrêter quand c'est un peu la
question qu'on se pose est-ce que c'est
pas une folie de vouloir comme ça courir
en permanence économique un fou rire en
permanence après l'inflation a essayé de
proposer des mesures pour contrer
l'inflation alors c'est difficile parce
que c'est d'inflation plus énergétiques
donc donc très volatile qui va continuer
à ce que je voulais dire pour rebondir à
ça c'est vrai qu'on parle beaucoup du
prix de l'énergie du pétrole mais on a
un peu oublié il ya la transition
écologique la transition écologique aura
un coût avant d'avoir de la création il
y aura de la destruction et pendant ces
premiers temps et bien il y aura un coût
qui va augmenter l'énergie donc même si
le pétrole baisse le gazon notamment
l'électricité ont beaucoup de processus
production vont aller sur l'électricité
sur le tout électrique il y aura des
hausses donc là aussi il faut vraiment
s'interroger sur l'anticiper et aussi
peut-être diversifiée en investissant
massivement on en a parlé dans
l'innovation pour essayer d'avoir
d'autres sources d'énergie en fait ne
pas remplacer le tout pétrole par le
tout électrique ou une toux gaz et donc
peut-être en fait avoir la même
dépendance à c'est vraiment important et
la transition aura un coût même si ces
crises là sont derrière nous a lancé sur
ce quoi qu'il en coûte on continue on
continue parce que c'est sûr qu'on a un
risque inflationniste mais on a quand
même des conditions on va dire
monétaires et budgétaires qui sont pour
l'instant favorable encore
aujourd'hui même si la banque centrale
européenne a dit qu'il va falloir aller
progressivement vers une politique moins
accommodante on sait à partir de l'année
prochaine au niveau de la commission
européenne qui va falloir essayer
d'aller vers une trajectoire des fameux
3% de déficit le pack stabilité de
croissance devrait être mis en oeuvre
donc il va falloir progressivement
peut-être pas assainir parce qu'on ne
pourra pas solder cette dette en
quelques années mais en tout cas montré
une trajectoire d'assainissement et
c'est là à mon sens que les dés vont
être jetés plus que les chiffres parce
qu'on va rester endettés comme ça assez
longtemps mais c'est d'avoir une
tragédie de désendettement et c'est là
aussi peut y avoir des différences entre
les états membres et des risques
d'attaqués sur les marchés financiers
sur ce que les états proposent s'il n'y
a pas des volontés d'endettement qui
sont assez importants le pour résumer un
peu c'est en effet on s'endette on
s'endette le problème c'est qu'on est
dans un monde excessivement à risque et
que dans tout cela est bien la dette
française en tout cas pour l'instant
reste encore assez sûr parce que leur s
en fait les beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
moins c'est un petit peu ça qu'il faut
avoir en tête et donc pas pour l'instant
on arrive à 6 ans et à des coûts encore
soutenable mais c'est vrai qu'à un
moment il va falloir aller vers des
politiques mandat comme autant mathieu
pour vous la succession de ces plans des
plans de résilience le dernier en date
ça va laisser des traces durables oui
parce que je pense que si on ajoute la
pandémie la flambée des prix d'énergie
qui a suivi la guerre en ukraine tout ça
ça fait exploser en plein vol des dogmes
de politique économique que l'on croyait
devenu intangible depuis plusieurs
décennies le premier c'est un dogme de
22 ans
on est passé de l'état ne peut pas tout
l'étape est en l'état ne peut pas tout
vous souvenez de cette petite phrase qui
a été prononcée par un préfet ni de
gauche lionel jospin à un moment où
michelin fermer une usine et là on était
vraiment dans une forme de désengagement
de 10 ans mais il ya l'économie de
marché et la société il faut pas que ce
soit une société de marché mais
l'économie de marché on la laisse faire
bref l'idée que c'est l'état ne pouvait
pas grand chose ils n'étaient pas
entendues des grands patrons aujourd'hui
ces cas du coup oublié enterrée par le
quoi qu'il en coûte on l'a dit une
formule qui ne m'appartient pas et même
de la crau faut le rappeler un mec avait
été inventé par mario draghi un moment
où il y avait la crise de l'euro et ce
quoi qu'il en coûte prononcée par le
patron de la banque centrale européenne
à l'époque c'était un signal vers les
marchés tandis qu'alou quoi qu'il en
coûte prononcé marc baron c'était un
signal vers les français le second dogme
qui a explosé en plein vol c'est un
dogme de 30 ans je moi je le mets à 30
ans et celui de la dette la fameuse
dette si on prend le critère de mettre
les critères de maastricht 1992 60% de
dette publique ça c'était vraiment le
maximum autorisé sinon n'était pas
qualifiée pour l'euro la monnaie unique
plamondon et à 114 113 ennemi c'est ça
en 116 wallace en 500 16% et le débat
n'est même plus de savoir qui
remboursera ni même comment on
remboursera et sur l'europe en date
récente sur l'europe on est aux
alentours de 60 oui mais cela à la
légère en france on a complètement fait
exploser ça alors qu'alice budgétaire à
polluer les débats publics et les battre
campagne pendant des années et des
années le troisième dogme c'est un homme
de 40 ans enfin jean montaldo 120 c'est
la dernière fois qu'on a nationalisé des
choses de l'année les nationalisations
après un essai de privatiser et là
souvenez-vous de cette petite phrase de
déminage macron au point au printemps de
l'huile de lin qu'avons nous fait peut
le souligner mais nous avons si j'ose
dire nationalisé le paiement des
salaires des ailes président ce qui est
vrai il disait ça n'a jamais existé dans
l'histoire économique contemporain on a
vu un peu les montants en jeu par le
chômage partiel notamment des secteurs
entiers ont été nationalisées à coups de
chizé chômage partiel d'indemnisation de
chiffre d'affaires perdu ou de manque à
gagner je pense à des secteurs entiers
la culture la restauration ont vécu sous
perfusion pendant des mois j'ai dû
passer une mauvaise chose mais bref on a
fait exploser des dogmes qui était
absolument impensable jusque là alors
justement est ce que est ce que ça peut
être une bonne chose la réponse est pas
simple alors c'est difficile
de répondre de façon binaire à mes yeux
oui parce que la solidarité a joué à
plein et qui on peut se féliciter que
après tout c'est bien le rôle de l'état
d'être une forme de cars en dernier
ressort de la bonne marche du pays de la
cohésion de la nation de l'économie oui
non en revanche si on estime que cette
solidarité n'a joué une fois plus que
dans un sens au nom du bon vieux
principe qui veut qu'on nationalise les
pertes et qu'on privatise les bénéfices
et la jean luc mélenchon dans un
raccourci un peu expéditif a quand même
montré que toutes sont avait mobilisé
par pour le quoi qu'il en coûte
correspondait bon an mal an à vélo
bénéfices qu'avaient fait les
milliardaires sur sur la période récente
on peut juger ça démagogique c'est quand
même des masses de chiffres qui qui qui
se correspondent et donc
on parlait total tout à l'heure
total il a fallu que total engrangé des
bénéfices considérables pour que cette
entreprise se disant à faire un geste de
solidarité un chèque de 100 euros à ses
abonnés en situation de précarité
énergétique voix gc oui aussi on peut
dire que c'est une bonne chose parce que
ça revenait une forme de poids à l'état
dans les milieux économiques dans les
décisions économiques faut savoir que
bercy avant c'était même plus écoutée
par quand vous êtes patron du cac 40
vous étiez convoqué à bercy vous y
alliez si vous aviez envie d'y aller
aujourd'hui ils vous parlent un peu
meilleures et surtout un moment où la
souveraineté économique industriel
devient un vrai enjeu c'est plutôt mieux
que l'état retrouve une forme de place
et puis en enchaînant si ça devient un
changement culturel qui transforme notre
économie sans système de subsides
permanente du ou des ouanna
faisons le choix de l'économie
administrée ce n'est pas le cas on voit
bien avec tous ces chèques qui se
succèdent le truc de bloquer les prix on
essaie plutôt de mettre du jour dans le
sable mais est ce qu'on aura de plus en
plus de sable et de plus en plus
d'offres aurait réagi par rapport à
vous avez cité beaucoup de choses l'idée
c'est de dire pourquoi il ya ces
changements fait fondamentaux c'est
parce que tous les chocs exogènes dont
beaucoup être plus macro économiques et
mondiaux et donc les réponses tout ce
qu'on attend depuis les années 80 c'est
une dérégulation et une augmentation de
la mondialisation et donc on mettait les
états entre concurrence et on regardait
comment un état en fonction de la bonne
gestion des finances publiques de bons
indicateurs économiques est bien arrivé
à absorber être bon ou pas et s'il était
bon en effet la vaccination sur les
marchés sinon ils étaient accentués là
on n'est plus du tout là dedans que ce
soit dans le choc écologique numérique
et démographique et toutes les crises
qu'on va avoir en effet sécuritaire ou
sanitaire la réponse ne peut plus être
dans la compétition entre les états mais
doit être une réponse globale on l'a vu
au début de la crise toutes les
politiques monétaires se sont mis
ensemble pour dire attention il faut pas
qu'on soit dans la crise de 2008 donc
c'est vraiment ensemble qu'on arrivera à
s'en sortir donc les chocs et les cris
seront tellement macro les chocs
exogènes seront tellement important que
ce n'est pas au niveau des pays seul
confort avons une réponse mais c'est
vraiment au niveau du bloc de groupe ce
qu'on voit à la glace heures etats unis
chine europe oui et notamment la réponse
européenne alors c'était l'une des
questions je vais vous poser tellement
désaccord
mais quand même depuis trois semaines
l'europe
fait une démonstration d'unité d'une
réactivité qu'on le connaissait
peut-être pas forcément ou
systématiquement est ce que ça vous fait
changer un peu haute vision de l'europe
de l'est nations européennes
effectivement les nations européennes
ont été solidaires déjà pour accueillir
les réfugiés le craignent un ensuite
pour élaborer des sanctions contre
contre la russie est effectivement mais
moi je sais me européenne ans et les
nations européennes et yale il ya une ya
une nuance et c'est vrai que l'europe
c'est pas une structure technocratique
politique qui est responsable du chômage
de masse de la précarité des
délocalisations parce que ce qui vient
d'être dit très justement par matthieu
croissandeau sur cette analyse
finalement d'un monde qui s'est
effondrée ce monde de la globalisation
ce monde du mondialisme les frontières
devaient s'abattre il ya plus de
protection les crises ont rappelé que
les nations était important que les
souverainetés été essentiel dans le
monde où nous sommes parce que la
souveraineté énergétique l essentiel
pour ne pas être dépendant des grandes
puissances la souveraineté alimentaire
on le voit bien et la souveraineté
économique je n'en parle pas donc c'est
assez d'ailleurs si on fait la
transition avec les annonces de monsieur
castex quand ils cherchent finalement à
me dire qu'il ne se passe et du gaz
russe d'ici 2027 serait une folie ça
lancerait de manière irrémédiable la
russie dans les bras de la chine je
rappelle que deux buts depuis 2022 le
début de l'année 2022 il ya eu des
exportations en hausse de 41% donc de la
chine vers la russie donc ce qui
évidemment
entretien ce pacte entre la russie la
chine qui n'est pas pour servir nos
intérêts mais remplacé ce gaz russe par
du gaz naturel liquéfié dont les
principaux producteurs sont les états
unis notamment et le qatar donc changer
une dépendance pour une autre ce serait
évidemment très mauvais pour nos
intérêts à nous et je ne vois pas
finalement quelle serait la résilience
qu'elle allait passer de la russie au
qatar eric delannoy moins de réponses
enfin je suis toujours très étonné un
peu juge toujours un peu suspect cette
cette propension forte du rassemble
nationale a minimisé ce qu'il faut faire
contre la russie mais d'abord la france
est un des pays d'europe qui a la
moindre exposition par rapport aux pays
d'europe sur le gaz naturel russe donc
nous sommes probablement le pays qui
peut s'en passer le plus facilement
premièrement deuxièmement on a quand
même un impératif quand on parle de
souveraineté qui a la meilleure chose au
monde on voit bien que c'est la
meilleure chose qui est capable de fouet
de manière extrêmement violente en en
commander à jean marc en foulant aux
pieds tous les droits international donc
plus cette souveraineté on arrivera là
mutualisé dans des blocs qui permettent
de feu
propos un peu un peu étrange quand aux
données économiques il est bien évident
que par exemple le plan énergétique qui
a été annoncé par emmanuel macron il ya
maintenant trois semaines va dans le
sens d'une appli d'une plus grande
indépendance énergétique alors on peut
se poser la question de savoir si ça a
été fait à retard ou pas le retard est
en majorité expliqué par le fait qu'il a
souhaité mettre en place une commission
extrêmement pointus sérieuse pour
pouvoir choisir en connaissance de cause
et non pas sur des slogans visent
l'électoralisme donc ça a pris deux ans
donc voilà mais on en a maintenant une
politique énergétique qui fait qu'on va
pouvoir s'en passer ça prendra du temps
le 2027 il est probablement très
ambitieux mais nous avons des réserves
potentielles par rapport à nos
partenaires comme la norvège et comme
l'algérie ce qui permet par ailleurs de
vie revigorer une politique
méditerranéenne qui aujourd'hui avec les
mêmes mis un peu sous le boisseau donc
il me semble que tout ça peut accoucher
de quelque chose de positif dernier
point quand on parle de d'efforts des
nations versus efforts de l'europe bien
évidemment je suis pas du tout d'accord
puisque la l'union européenne est en
train de montrer qu'elle devienne forces
internationales et elle avait commencé
par sa capacité à voir une bande
centrale européenne qui permette de
soutenir l'ensemble des économies et
c'est bien la banque centrale européenne
qui soutient les échos 90 jours sur
l'édition je vais vous donner la parole
mais d'abord octobre à portage un mot à
mot là dessus sur le finalement le
l'action de l'union européenne comment
vous la voulez value et est ce que vous
êtes plutôt
proche de julien odoul dans son analyse
ou d' eric delannoy
il ya plusieurs sujets sur la sur la
question européenne nous on n'a jamais
été pour la sortie de l'euro pour un tir
open simplement ce qu'on remet en cause
c'est l'europe libérale et ce qu'elle
engendre comme des régulations et
notamment gevo quelques heures les
questions de l'énergie si aujourd'hui on
a une minute l explosion des factures et
compris en amont de la guerre c'est
qu'il y avait eu ce qu'on appelle au
parlement européen des paquets de
libéralisation qui avaient voté la
dérégulation des services publics et
tout à l'heure vous avez rappelé les
dogmes qui ont volé en éclats depuis
quelques semaines oui la question des 3%
on a vu que ça ne tenait pas la route on
a vu que le marché était responsable du
chaos et que toutes celles et ceux qui
nous expliquait qu'il fallait une libre
concurrence non faussée et aucune
intervention de l'état venait réclamer
des aides publiques et de l'argent
public pour les accompagner et quand
j'entends qu'on parle du bilan parce que
jean castex a aussi évoqué tout à
l'heure la question de l'être mission
écologique et la question énergétique on
à l'engagement qu'il faut développer les
énergies renouvelables et aujourd'hui la
france est le seul pays de l'union
européenne qui ne respecte pas ses
engagements de mètres aux alentours de
23 % c'était l'objectif d'énergies
renouvelables on est à peine à 19 on est
en retard sur l'innovation des logements
thermique on est face à un président qui
a fermé des lignes de train par exemple
et qui a remis un maximum de camions et
de voitures sur les routes donc on voit
que entre les discours de jean castex du
gouvernement et les actions sur le
terrain il ya une réalité qui est
absolument disparates et qui pénalise au
quotidien des millions de français
répondent général qui sont mobiles en
vous faites vous de l'action de l'union
européenne depuis trois semaines depuis
le début de l'invasion de l'ukraine par
la russie
je crois que les sanctions financières
qui sont pris à l'encontre de la dîmière
poutine elles sont d'une utilité
nécessaire absolument importante mais
nous ce qu'on demande c'est qui est une
initiative de paix très forte pour
sortir cette guerre parce que la seule
chose qui doit nous animer aujourd'hui
c'est la paix et je remets ici sur la
table la proposition qui est celle de
jean luc mélenchon de réunir ce qu'on
appelle la bce pour avoir une grande
confiance de la paix qui met à la fois
l'union européenne qui met la russie qui
mènent la chaîne et les états unis
autour de la table pour sortir de ce
conflit parce que la seule résolution
elle est pacifique et bien sûr qu'il
faut aussi s'engager dans les sanctions
financières plus fortement vis-à-vis des
oligarques russes on a des biens qui
sont identifiés en france qui appartient
à des proches de vladimir poutine qui se
sont enrichis grâce à lui et avec l'aide
de la russie qu'attend emmanuel macron
pour aller saisir c'est bien là
notamment la villa de l'ancien président
du club de foot de chelsea roman
abramovitch qui est sûr le port
d'antibes on sait où aller il faut
mettre la pression financière sur ses
soutiens là pour faire exploser ce
président et mettre fin à cette guerre
qui abominable alors certains biens ont
été saisis notamment le yacht d'un de
ces oligarques je voudrais concret
je donnais juste cette information à
propos de la dette je vous propose
d'écouter valérie pécresse était ce
matin elle cherche sur cette question là
à se démarquer des autres candidats elle
était face aux patrons la cgpme on
écoute j'ai dans mon programme l'idée
d'une règle d'or budgétaire
constitutionnel qui obligerait l'état se
mette dans une trajectoire pour revenir
à 3% de déficit mon objectif c'est qu'on
ne lègue pas aux générations futures une
dette financière abyssal il d'ailleurs
une dette écologique parce que je pense
que le rôle d'un gouvernance est plus
chère du court terme c'est de faire du
long terme je le g2 s'est effectivement
disparu et c'est aussi le medef est pas
le cnpf effective au fessier dans
l'époque redevenons sérieux social
sifflant l'endettement moi j'ai
l'impression que c'est un peu une drogue
dure pour les politiques et que la cure
de désintox ça doit être content alors
oui c'est une drogue dure que ceux comme
on l'a dit avec ce contexte
inflationniste sidéens et on l'a vu dans
l'histoire à l'inflation peut conduire à
beaucoup de choses donc c'est vraiment
une crainte pour beaucoup de
gouvernements d'avoir vraiment une
érosion importante du pouvoir d'achat
qui est souvent plus du ressenti que ce
qui peut être effective donc c'est en
effet une priorité des c'est d'avoir des
mesures pour essayer de financer des
aides ponctuelles ou pas aidé d'utiliser
un ce contexte international de
financement qui est quand même plutôt
positif juste par rapport à ça on parle
de moyen long terme c'est vrai que le
m'étonne et on regarde beaucoup ça
économiquement tout on est très content
de dire en effet convient vers les blocs
vers le régionalisme vert voilà plus
d'indépendance de souveraineté
au niveau du national apprend que par et
pour ou contre la mondialisation il faut
quand même savoir que après l'ère la
seconde guerre mondiale c'était quoi
aussi le dogme qui revêt de sousse et
commerçons ayons des chances pour
justement de plus faire la guerre parce
qu'on l'avait yeux en 45 et donc il a
aussi volé en éclats
complètement dans tout le monde est de
plus en plus indépendants en effet en
disant ben voilà demain il ya un conflit
éclate ailleurs sépare avons négligé
pendant donc je ne dis pas les sont
fermées en tout cas on est moins
concerné donc ça continue et puis nous
principal si on est indépendant et bien
même s'il faut faire des sanctions c'est
cela donc ça aussi il faut quand même le
dire derrière on peut mais pas la
mondialisation belle idée du lien et
aussi au niveau des processus productifs
d'avoir cette vision mondiale s'était
aussi baisser les coûts et il faut dire
quand même cool tout le pouvoir d'achat
des français qu'on a eu depuis 20 ans
c'est dû à l'arrivée des produits
chinois sur nos marchés donc c'est bien
d'avoir en effet tout ça mais
économiquement il ya des conséquences et
donc si on est fait en revient vers plus
d'intégration eh bien c'est l'échec dont
on parle au niveau de l'énergie ce ne
sera pas que au niveau d'énergie mais ce
sera pour l'ensemble des biens et ça il
faut aussi le préparer l'enfant est ce
que ça veut dire sur nos modes de
consommation est ce qu'il ya une
contradiction finalement dans l'objectif
qui est celui principal de marine le pen
depuis effectivement plusieurs mois qui
est de soutenir le pouvoir d'achat des
français non il n'y a aucune
contradiction et il est vrai que la
baisse des prix et notamment faire appel
à des produits de bien piètre qualité
aller les chercher au bout du monde en
chine au canada au brésil effectivement
ça eu des effets délétères ne serait ce
que pour l'emploi pour nos capacités de
souveraineté industrielle et puis pour
la santé on oublie cette fête donnée
fondamentale les traités de libre
échange ou aussi dégradé la santé des
français mais qu avec et dévalisé
c'était odieux qualité qui en découle
prison voilà comment localiser ces
produits sans créer de l'inflation et
donc sans rogner sur le pouvoir d'achat
des français finalement mais j'ai il
faut changer de modèle économique mais
ça passe par des priorités ça passe par
des réalités de ce que l'on peut
produire de ce que l'on peut
remettre au goût du jour dans notre
territoire et puis de se passer de
l'idéologie du bloc parce que moi j'ai
entendu finalement ce qu'on entend
depuis des années les européistes
flamboyant on sera plus forts ensemble
l'allemagne vient de vous apporter un
démenti mais cinglant à l'allemagne qui
re militarise ne favorise pas
l'industrie française l'industrie
militaire française mais favorise les
américains en achetant des avions de
combat américains annoncent qu'ils aient
ce qui montre bien que finalement votre
idéologie du bloc européen de dire qu'on
va faire de l'europe une puissance
souveraine tout ça c'est une chimère
comme l'europe de la défense est une
chimère comme l'europe de la santé comme
tout ce que les dogmes ultralibéraux que
vous allez vous lui vendre la nation
aujourd'hui le seul instrument de
protection pour les français protéger
leur emploi leur pouvoir d'achat et
aussi parce que c'est important leur
sécurité eric delannoy non alors bien
sûr sûr je reviens sur ce qui vient
d'être dit sur le sur le sur le
convoyage le dogme qui serait sorte fin
qui serait tombée sur la guerre vers
jean bédard les choses quand même sur la
décision de l'allemagne baladé sur
l'allemagne ça veut dire pour moi qui
ajuste un chemin faire je veux dire
l'europe de la défense on en parle
depuis 25 ans on ne l'a jamais mis de
manière aussi concrètes sur la table que
depuis quinze jours donc on va on va se
calmer un peu enfin je veux dire que les
amériques que les allemands achète des
avions américains c'est une péripétie de
l'histoire par rapport à ce qui vient de
se passer sur le fait qu'on décide
d'avoir une défense européenne
maintenant il ya du chemin à faire je
suis assez d'accord sur le fait que rien
n'est parfait je veux dire la communauté
et que milito européenne l'union
européenne elle s'est faite aujourd'hui
en 70 ans il faut se rappeler que les
états unis ça s'est fait en plus de 150
ans avec une bière au milieu qui a fait
six cent mille morts donc on n'en est
pas encore là donc donc moi je pense
qu'il faut laisser du temps au temps ça
c'est quand le premier point le deuxième
point limite noël vite la seconde c'est
que je pense que en fait on continue à
ne pas se faire la guerre parce que
potentiellement aujourd'hui les
sanctions économiques nous évite d'aller
mettre des soldats au front qui ont su
tuer et peut-être que s'il est de la
chine ne soutient pas plus le la russie
aujourd'hui c'est parce qu'elle a
conscience qu'elle fait dix fois plus
d'échangés avec les états unis et
l'europe et on termine sur quelques
averses et la russie à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat ici était en duplex